- [Interviewer] Do you have a favorite
character from the show?
- I think the only answer to
that question is probably Tina.
(ukulele strumming)
My name is Andrew Rea, I
host a YouTube cooking show
called Binging With Babish,
where I recreate the foods
from movies and television.
Binging With Babish, a lot of people think
that my name is Oliver Babish, it's not.
Oliver Babish is a character
from maybe three episodes
of The West Wing, a show that I love.
I kinda started making the show just
because I bought a camera and lights,
and I wanted to practice
my food photography,
and I thought it would
be fun to make a burger
from Parks and Rec.
It just sort of grew and grew,
and now it's my full-time job.
So today we're making the
"Baby You Can Chive My Car"
burger, from Bob's Burgers.
This was one of the most
requested burgers on the show.
And we're gonna start with a
step that most people forget.
I'm gonna toast our buns.
Be a good guy and toast
your buns for once.
Droppin' in the buns.
I've never seen Bob toast
his buns on the show,
but again, this is a man who cares
about the quality of his food.
And anybody who knows burgers,
and Bob knows his burgers,
knows that you gotta toast your bun.
Come on, buddy.
We have four toasted buns.
Let us fry.
It's gonna get a little
smokey in here, folks.
The price you pay for good food.
I'm just hittin' these with just salt
and freshly ground pepper.
That is all that they need.
That is all they want.
Two minutes, it'll slide right off.
(playful claves with soft guitar picking)
I started cooking when
I was like 10 or 11.
My Mom taught me how to cook.
She passed away when I was very young,
so it's a nice way to just
sort of feel closer to her.
Food's always been a huge part of me,
and you know, so has film,
so it's a really nice way
to combine those two things,
I'm very happy that I found a career
that allows me to do that.
Alright, I'm calling these done.
No real cheese or
condiments on this burger,
except for a healthy dollop of sour cream,
it goes with the chives.
This wouldn't be the "Baby
You Can Chive My Car" burger
without lots and lots
of chives, top it up.
It wouldn't be the "Car" burger
without our fried pickle wheels.
I'm gettin' ready to
bread our pickles here.
And I'm doing the classic
wet hand, dry hand method
for breading these.
That way you only have
one hand touching the egg,
one hand touching the flour.
We are frying.
When you're laying things down in oil,
lay them down away from you,
flip it away from you, your hands
and your family and friends.
There we go, we have
our fried pickle wheels.
Going to impale them.
Just gonna slip 'em right in there.
That's, is the "Baby You
Can Chive My Car" burger.
Vroom, vroom.
I'm excited to see if people
like this as much as I do.
- Ahhhh.
- Oh my god.
- It's so cute.
- Ha!
Cute little buggy.
- Are those chicken nuggets?
- No they're, they're fried pickles.
It's like a car, it has little wheels.
- Fucking love fried pickles.
- I love fried pickles.
- So we have to guess
the name of the burger.
I'm not punn-ing.
- I know the name of the burger.
- You do?
- Baby you can.
- Chive my car.
- Oh my god.
- Cheers, oh my gosh.
(light jazzy music)
- Mmm.
- Oh hell yeah.
- Mm hmm.
- Oh yeah.
Mm hmm.
- Fuck yeah.
That is not a cartoon burger.
That's like legit shit.
- Love it.
- The pickle is definitely
a very important addition,
like it adds a really nice like crunch.
- I really love sour cream.
- Same.
- And it's like the perfect
balance with the pickle.
- Yeah, just up the chives I think.
- We're chivey people.
- Yeah, we're chivey people.
Really amazing display by the way.
- That was the coolest
burger I've ever seen.
- These are the kinds of
burgers that they make
at Bob's Burgers.
- Why were they not more successful?
- Like, I really want
like, Bob to serve me this.
- Yeah.
- Because I think the whole part
of the Bob's Burgers experience is.
- [Dark-Haired Girl] Is the characters.
- [Green Sweater Guy]
It's the diner, it's the.
- [Dark-Haired Girl] The family.
- I feel like I just went to Bob's Bugers
and I ordered a burger,
and that's like, my dream.
- I just can't believe they
actually taste like that.
I thought they were just
like crappy burgers.
- Bring us more. (laughing)
- Andrew, come back.
- Or someone named Bob.
- Someone named Bob.
- Bring a Bob.
- Just a Bob, any Bob.
- [Dark-Haired Girl] Just any kind of Bob,
bring him over here and
make him make us a burger.
- [Green Sweater Guy] Just a Bob, any Bob.
(swishing wind)
(squeaky hinge)